こんにちははじめ社長です皆様は僕のお母様の存在をご存知でしょうか
コードネーム n ommy 波あの
[音楽]
アン中ですねまぁ機と優した軽くルアンつだと思うんですけど基本的に僕のギャル動画
になりとも文句を言っていきますそんなお母様が今ぼくドエルっておりまして今日は
なんと特別でしょ皆さん特区別でしょ本当に本当に特別です
基本的に僕んちの家の人はどんなに出たくないドルに出たくないしてもう多分今日は
いやいやだと思うんですけども
富士
お母様が動画に出てくれることを得てくれます
ただ条件としては顔を出さな声を出すなずつな黙秘権を使わせると4つの条件が出て
おりますのでそれを保った上で今からツイッターでちょっとみなさまで僕のお母ちゃん
マミーに聞きたいことをちょっと募集しますのでバンバンと見つけたものから順番
ちょっと色々聞いていきたいと思いますでは以降1位歳
ておりませんしてください皆様でございますぜひいつかけどぼさんだしてくるって言っ
ていない
ちゃんとどう味出し言っておきましたなんとか総局を受けました
じゃあ範囲の時はこの丸を使ってください
はいはい
ですうん良いへの轍がコッシーに置くの音のクリー権を縫製する時はこちらを使って
ください
じゃあ起こった時はこれを使ってください皆早速てツイッター民から募集してみ
ましょう
甘みが来てるよって
ええええ未だツイッターで募集しますお母様に何か質問ある
はしだがはじめママに質問よしオッケーですはいちょっとゆるきたので早速聴いていき
ましょう
肇社長は子どものころどんな方
どういうこともダメなどですということ
どんな感じでしたかあっはぁっ
ブーバて大変縫う方法
ブーバーはじめパンッ
の育児法線的なものはありましたか
ダメなものはダメ hey 一貫して台のはいいよね
インフルエヌエー
大事なことですなかなか旬な話題が飛んでおりますが始めママに質問
はじめの拍動がどう思いました
はぁ鉄はじめママに質問はじめの武勇伝
ん
の発作てながら言った
死にかけてた時あったまあこれでもコズン的なでも気になるな
お気に入りの動画とかありますかませんあマジまろイギリスのだけがバージョンあろう
場所分
どんどん今日って
ブーバー路線しかあっ ok あつっ
ブーブー言い結構多いよねはじめ骨質問
息子がこんなに馬鹿で困りませんかいただけます
理由それはこれはすげえなはじめママに質問はじめいう千葉以外の職業何してほしい
はい
だって教員は世の中の見えなくです
昔パイアになりた花と授業と者があっても食にこだわりないん
もうスムーズに前が私えっあっ
ないということで背後ではね皆招き良くないか逆に知りたいな
反抗期の思い出とかありますか
字幕に目せる時に東京 a depot 資産を持っている
うん中が前田家の写真全部アスリ考えた中二病の東京
ブーブー時期があっああっ女神火あっはじめに
腹が立っていること
実際人からすぎて一貫しておりますねそこは youtube はじめた時どう思い
ましたか
大丈夫ってなかったけどいつ気付いたの
これが youtube だよってどうでしたあ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ